hola buenas tardes era nuestro estudio
quería digamos confirmar algo que todos
sospechábamos y es que los micro
plásticos están tan presentes en nuestro
medio ambiente que también
penetran nuestras barreras y pueden
acabar en el medio interno entonces la
primera la primera pregunta que teníamos
esto si si esto era correcto si esto es
verdad para luego a continuación pasar a
otro tipo de estudios donde es donde
aclaremos cuáles son las implicaciones
biomédicas de este de hallazgo y cuáles
son los pasos a seguir entonces no hacía
referencia a que se vienen más estudios
efectivamente lo primero que hemos
podido constatar es que si los micro
plásticos están presentes en la sangre
eso significa que han pasado las
barreras naturales del organismo es
decir la piel
las mucosas
y que por lo tanto
cuál es el mecanismo por el que esto
ocurre si hay algún tipo de célula que
los capturas por ejemplo en el intestino
en el epitelio respiratorio y los pasa
dentro del torrente circulatorio es la
primera pregunta que tenemos cuál es el
mecanismo por el que esto ocurre otra de
las preguntas que tenemos es qué ocurre
con estos micro plásticos una vez que
están dentro de la sangre como todos
sabemos los micros plásticos no se
degradan tan fácilmente se depositan en
los tejidos en qué en qué tejidos se
depositan posibles que se decreten
itziar y si están presentes en los
tejidos cuánto tiempo y cuáles son las
consecuencias de la presencia del
plástico en los tejidos hacia este modo
este último punto apunta mi pregunta no
se sabe al menos algunas de las
implicancias que tiene para la salud del
individuo la presencia de micro
plásticos en su sangre
nuestro por ahora podemos solamente
especular
los micro plásticos tienen dos tipos de
peligros desde mi punto de vista en
primer lugar pueden actuar como vectores
para
factores macro microbiológico que pueden
causar enfermedad puesto que los micro
plástico están en el medio ambiente se
pueden contaminar con virus o bacterias
y esto puede y puede trasladar estos
dentro del organismo son por un lado por
otro lado son sustancias químicas de
hecho con polímeros que no son
sustancias naturales para el organismo y
que pueden desencadenar las reacciones
inflamatorias dentro del organismo ya se
ha demostrado en estudios in vitro que
los micro plásticos pueden actuar
activar la la
emisión
todo tipo de mediadores inflamatorios y
factores reactivos al oxígeno etcétera
entonces tras nuestro siguiente paso va
a ser investigar si esto puede
desencadenar algún tipo de reacción que
conlleve autoinmunidad alergia
cáncer todo tipo de enfermedades donde
el sistema inmunitario está implicado